I saw you were uh obviously uh for you
like
uh I saw one of your interviews you said
that you were getting off papers in 2023
are you officially off papers yep how's
that feel
they still on my like I don't know they
just
the the lmpd showed dirty and Louisville
like they
I guess like why you've seen that advice
like little police is different terrible
yeah like they
because it's like they you you have to
go and do the time you have to deal with
whatever you have to do you have to pay
your fine but then they kind of keep
like this invisible like these invisible
handcuffs on you through probation I
just always had a thing like with the
pro like I on I never had no no I never
like you know how I need to be acting
like people teach them a lot like the
police right like
I don't want to say his name I think he
got four he was involved in the Brianna
table [__] though one of the police
officers when I was little though he
walked like a little group of us home at
gunpoint though one of the dudes who
were involved in the ground yeah um
uh I won't say
Turtle Creek and she lives
yeah it was Turtle Creek or bang Creek I
forgot what number just got they right
next to each other but yeah so when you
were a kid you and your friends like got
walked home like the cop had y'all like
guns they wanted to do something Brianna
Taylor [__] that [__] just like
I don't know it just I I had my so I had
my own you had your own experience yeah
yeah I mean I see how they are on an
everyday basis I've been dealing with
these [__] my whole life yeah
ain't no police ain't they ain't never
helped me are they still like um making
it hard for you to do shows back home
yes I had a show booked at the Yum
Center
they told
whoever it is the security or whatever
people the engine told to promote they
didn't want me in there
then the promoters like all right well
I'ma just have just babied in and he was
like no because baby my child bring G
out because he did before like on
surprise some surprises so
yeah that's how they do uh you know
Mozzy right Mozzy in Sacramento they
won't let him perform nowhere that's
gotta be that's that and I do ain't
don't don't nobody do as much for the
city as as we do like
nobody like I didn't donate more money I
didn't gave did giveaways back to school
giveaways turkey drives Christmas [__]
you know I'm saying all type of [__] and
they act like it ain't nothing like the
last time I did a shoe giveaway last
year we gave away like retro Jordans
like good jewelry right right not the
team a whole lot of [__] like like
probably like five six hundred per shoes
like all Jordans and the powers that we
don't give a [__] and there was crowded
out there in the news the news station
made it look like
like it was a problem like it was a lot
of like they instead of reporting on
somebody giving all this stuff away to
yeah the city they they made it look
like it was Ruckus and the police had to
be called the controller system which
wasn't true the police just came because
that's what they do but it wasn't no
wasn't nothing going on out there you
know what I'm saying like
Jesus they just try to flip it and make
it something bad like
but a lot of it come from experience
certain people in the community too
because it ain't like
like I don't know a lot of Street [__]
that act like they so street but they
moms it should be police officers and
you know I'm saying Community Watch
[__] and then that turned into
you know I'm saying they tell one side
up and not the other side of it making
it look like a monster but you know what
I'm saying how do you feel like you need
a dry snitch to their moms and [__] fear
me uh tell them [__] that's going on and
then knowing that their mom yeah yeah
it's straight though I was gonna say do
you feel like when something like that
happens right like the news covers an
event that's supposed to be a positive
event for the community but they cover
it in a negative light is there anything
you can do to help control that
narrative
[__] I'm the one giving the [__] what
what more can you well like I feel like
you know like like when you go online
and like clear it up like hey today was
like a good day like
no cause it don't be mad you feel me
don't be mad I'm more of the gesture I
don't care how how you receive it I know
it's coming for you yeah you know I
ain't even attend the actual concrete
action though you feel me doing what I'm
doing like that's why I didn't matter I
feel like intentions
that's true that's true